[Music]
Freedom
yay always already
wholeness unconditional
love super simple and
ordinary just like these
alpacas they're just
chilling n
nom nom
noming
many of Y all likely know
that this has been going by Atlas for a
while and its birth name being arazi
Allen
Zakon and there was such a fascination
with
maps and there was such a fascination
with visualizing
the individual on its transformative
Journey number three is now here all
three are
here
and that has been
exhausted this summer there
were piles and piles of maps and
visualizations of again what's always
already wholeness always already
freedom
appearing as an individual that's on a
transformative Journey that's making
maps and
so
what was
clear is
that there was really an inability to
continue making
Maps it's just
unable because where where would one go
where would one that is already no thing
go how would one share a map about how
to be what one already is or how to get
something when it is already the
case so there had to
be a clear ceasing a clear
no longer interested in map
making no longer interested in carrying
the Mirage World on the
shoulders
Atlas or
Atlantis or the collection of maps into
an
atlas
these this obsession with maps this
obsession with Duality this obsession
with assisting an individual that's
already
nothing with Retreats or psychedelics or
books or gurus or spiritual paths
or anything that is not already
this just validates
the existence of a Seeker on a
journey where there
isn't
so
Maps validate an
ucer Seeker on a transformative journey
to
wholeness
so Maps inherently validate an
illusion maps are Santa
Claus maps are
spam Maps spelled backwards is
Spam their spam because how could you go
somewhere to become what you already
are they're Santa Claus
because they're an
illusion it's just the
story so in a way what is about to
be
shared
was
the
unraveling apparently of these
contractive threads that were an atlas
character that
was obsessed about maps and this was the
sort of the
final of
only four visuals that are all pretty
much have the same
backbone
so it's Freedom that's what it's called
and this is the on the website there's
only these four visuals under Freedom
there's homeow which is decentralizing
basic needs infrastructures and then
their simulation which is this show
so when you click
open this and I'll share that it
obviously it says there is only Freedom
appearing as this there is only
wholeness and you'll see there in the
first three images that and in the
fourth one you'll see that the elusory
individual or the contraction in the
body is on path to mutually assured
destruction or mad here in this
rainbow Earth it's neither real nor
unreal but apparently the contracted
individual is on path to mutually
assured
destruction
so when it's clicked open this
is this is that
first
visual this is what feels
like the last huzzah at being able to
visually
describe the
ineffable
TR trying to
put what
is ineffable into a
2d visual is
hilarious but this seemed to get as
close
as it felt
possible again it was hundreds of maps
hundreds of Concepts probably thousands
of Concepts on hundreds of maps with all
different kinds of colors and
visualizations and
stories that were seen to be
completely illusory a
complete
fabrication because there is no me
that's on a transformative Journey
there's always already only ESS and
freedom unconditional love appearing as
everything as what is and it can appear
as a contracted Center that's on a
journey to
wholeness and
so here the obviously the green and the
blue it's all up for your interpretation
obviously the green and the blue are the
two primary colors of land and ocean on
earth and all of those little black
lines are the
bodies
and they're kind of like the
Villi inside of the gastrointestinal
tract
and there's
this
black ether
unknown vast
expanse
no apparently being something and
everything and so the whole thing is not
to the whole thing is
indescribable
so this is how the ineffable is
appearing it does it no
justice
but the second
visual it continues to tell the story
through an
expansion um into that no thing being
everything
um all of this space time distance is
all elusory so everything is all
happening at once and there's no
separation and there's no uh part of the
ocean that is more real than another
part of the ocean
there's no
solidity there's no way to draw a box
around
you know there's a scale invariance
happening here this is the macro level
and this is the micro
level so you can see that scale
invariance but it's the same pattern but
at those two
scales and so there's
no there's no uh difference or
distinction besides what is artificially
constructed between the two
bodies or between all the
bodies there's no distinctions or
differences and then there's
uh there's the appearance of Distinction
and difference and location and
separation and
[Music]
others but that's just an ucer
appearance because there is only the
wholeness there is only the wholeness
that is
appearing
as this apparent
dance and
so
it is
quite
beautiful
because there's an
impossibility of being able to take a
portion of the ocean draw an ucer box
around it and then compare it to another
ucer bounded portion of the ocean and
say
that that it's right or that it's wrong
or that it's better or it's worse or
that
it's it's all water or air or wind or
energy or appearance or just what is
it's all just what
is it's all just wholeness appearing
it's all wholeness
appearing you know that's what this is
this is all wholeness appearing all of
it and
so in the third
visual there's
a an ADD addition to the first visual
which is adding these names and here the
names are Bob Karen Sam but they can be
any Chinese or Arabic or African or
Latin American or european or whatever
names it literally doesn't
matter what names are inserted
here the point is that the names
themselves are a label that is SL AP
onto the body when the body itself
doesn't have a name the body itself is
identityless it already is
nameless no thing wholeness is already
nameless it's already position it's
already everywhere
everything no thingness it's already
that and then there's all that again a
story but that conditioning of
appearance and teachers and Society
saying you are this and you are separate
from that so you are Bob and you're
separate from
Karen and so now prove yourself worthy
through how much you know to Karen to
earn her validation to earn her
respect and so wholeness is
just
position
playing all kinds of nonsensical ucer
games cuz it's the same no thing that's
with itself without any distance time
separation
anything so here you begin to see
that
where there's a contracted
assumption that is I'm
my name I'm
separate get some more of that alpaca
action
yeah
that it's obvious that then that Center
Point which is auser is going to
begin having a sense of lack having a
sense of others all kinds of
dualistic
experience
and it's always already made of that
wholeness that doesn't have name that
doesn't have position that doesn't have
a lack the name is just something that's
apparent so this is apparently
Atlas apparently arazi Allen sakan it's
apparently
that but it's wholeness being body
wholeness is
[Music]
bodying and that's the case everywhere
everywhere is just Infinity bodying
wholeness bodying no thing
boundlessness
bodying it's all
that and that's what's clear
here what's clear here is that is
this it's totally
it
that's
mysteriously
beautifully appearing as
this and here's the fourth one and this
one this one is doing its best to
not validate the dualism of there being
an
actual real contraction in the body that
is
really on a path towards mutually
assured
destruction because all of this is just
an appearance it's all just an elusory
appearance because it is actually
actually the wholeness that is
undergoing said
dream and
so what this is this last is image
is is
communicating is what you see as the
military industrial complexes and all
kinds of proliferation of nuclear
weapons and all of those stories of pain
and suffering and separation and
religious Warfare and warfare over
resources and all that kind of
stuff all of that is a product of
wholeness undergoing the appearance of a
contraction into a Center Point into a
me that is obsessed about its ideas it's
obsessed about its knowing obsessed
about my country my nation my identity
My Religion my land all of that is my my
my my my which is better than yours
yours yours yours smarter than yours
yours
yours more at one with God
or
whatever and so
because I'm more worthy and I'm more
special than you and I know more than
you then this contraction is I don't
have a problem with dropping nuclear
weapons on you I don't have a problem
with tanking or bombing
or
um killing with machine guns I don't
have a problem with any of that that
because you're an other you're not the
wholeness you're not
that and so that that
contraction is all about
me it's all
about having no issue whatsoever with
mutually assured destructions no issue
at all with
it
so every single War every single proxy
war every single geopolitical dispute
that's
happening is wholeness appearing as a
geopolitical dispute it's unconditional
love appearing as war and violence and
bombs being
dropped equally as much as its wholeness
appearing like
pizza
and
beer and
music and
trees and
so
apparently that contraction in the body
again just the story under
goes whatever
transformative experience is to see how
big of an illusion it is to chase
after whatever it's looking for whatever
it's seeking you know so me will seek
will chase
will do what whatever it can to try to
find what's not lacking so wholeness is
never lost but me thinks through
experiences it can get wholeness so it
doesn't have a problem with mad in the
sense of military but it also doesn't
have a problem with mad in terms
of uh acquisition it will acquire its
way also it will have uh billions or
billions of
dollars
before
it even questions ah maybe this is
not maybe I there is no way to find
wholeness through acquisition maybe it's
already
wholeness
and so it doesn't have an issue with
going and getting whatever
material
whatever extravagant luxurious material
insatiably and just getting getting
getting more more more me me me more
need need need lack lack lack lack so
that's how
mad
appears so it's all just a bunch of
Separation porn
so it's just like sitting and eating
popcorn while watching separation porn
while watching
wholeness appearing as
separation and it's no different than
sports or movie
it's just
that it's happening it's apparently
happening at
a at a geopolitical narrative level and
so that's why
they're ramped up anxiety and ramped
up
it's just the wind that's blowing it's
just this this
is just unconditional love being it's
just
that and all of this is story everything
here is just story and that's why these
visual are like some sort of sendoff
of this will
never be an accurate way of depicting
the mystery it's impossible to depict
the
mystery
visually it's just not
possible
it's impossible to tell a story about
the mystery or about
freedom because in doing so you bound
it
so no no
thing can't say that it looks like this
or that it looks like that because those
are just boxes those are just bounds
those are just
stories so you can say it's
everything and that includes war and
pizza
and wholeness is unconditional of
wholeness is
freedom
no
meaning is
freedom it's always here it's always
wholeness it's always no one everything
it's always that it's always
infinity it's never been lost and it
can't be found and none of these visuals
none of them
are even
close depictions of what
is no movie book Retreat experience Guru
visual
nothing no amount of
meditation
can assist leaving
what always
is there is no leaving what this
is that's another way of saying it
there's no leaving
everything there's only
everything there's no leaving it there's
no leaving Infinity there's no leaving
it
yes fam get to see y'all in the
chat
so a
nice send off with visuals
impossible
to ever
describe but
some
visuals in a fun attempt to do
so so there's just never any separation
there's never been separation there will
never be
separation there will never be
anything that's not holess there will
never be non-freedom there will never be
bondage it is impossible for bondage to
ever be it can ucer appear to
be as a tight experience in the
body but it's made of Freedom it's made
of
wholeness
there really isn't
more to
say and again everything that's been
said does not take first of all there is
no one so no one is moving closer to
what already is or further from it's not
possible so this
whole it's just some sort of
exhausting of
these
visuals
and all of these hundreds of maps and
thousands of Concepts and only being
able to put it into four of these
visuals
and even these four visuals don't even
get close to
it so there will never be a map all maps
are spam Maps backwards all maps are
spam because there's already no one home
no one is home always and forever
already there's always already forever
no mean no separation no individual
uality It's Always Forever
wholeness looking for it is missing
it looking for it in maps or books or
Retreats or
psychedelics or healing Shadow work
traveling material
possessions
relationships sex children family
looking for it looking for
it through objects of any sort of all of
those sorts is missing what already
is so if family appears or psychedelic
appears or book appears or video
appears or car appears or whatever a
travel appears it's what's appearing
it's what is it's what is it's just what
is it's already Freedom appearing as
that it's already wholeness appearing as
that it is not there is going to be
something that is gotten out of this
that is going to make
wholeness only me
structures
and perceives from a center point that
is trying to get what's missing through
all of those
objects so no one is fearlessly free to
Roar to just be free
to just say
no
no it's not going to be found if there's
pressure that's coming there's just
going to be a natural body response
which is no it's not going to be found
because it's not lost and it's quite a
shock
to me that is pressuring
ah you should read this book you should
travel to this place you should go on
this Retreat you
should do another psychedelic you should
have children in a family you
should buy a car and a house you should
this you should that you should and
that's The Narrative of me The Narrative
of me is always taking its duality I and
you should and ideas and it's always
pedling
it it's always trying to manipulate
change or control the
appearance in a way that for it to feel
whole but it can't because it's
already trying to manipulate and change
what
is
to find a sense of wholeness that is not
lost it's not lost it's never
lost and so it's beautiful because no
one just Roars it's just beautiful it's
like collie
is just an unknowing and no thinging
that is so beautifully ordinary and
Powerful it's just like the alpacas or
the cats or the dogs or the innocent
babies children
playing the unconditional love it's just
that and it just can't be manipulated it
can't be manipulated one this this can't
when there's no position when there's no
location that's
happening there's no more manipulation
that can
happen because the
manipulation
was
from a center point with another Center
Point
apparently so wholeness when dreaming as
two separate Center
points all kinds of
conditionality is happening all kinds of
conditional love all kinds of
conditional
relating and then when the individual
apparently drops away and it's seen that
never was and there's always been
locationless position no
thinging no one does not repress
everything just freely flows there's no
more straight jacket and so when that me
that Center Point is aggressively trying
to manipulate and control no one just
fearlessly
responds
and makes it clear that there's already
no one
there you're not
real and
that's very annoying to a sense of me
that is always wanting something always
needing
something and so either it
will leave it will
fight it
will if there's that
tiny
opening of
Unknowing of the
ineffable of no
one it can
also
unwind
but there's no one that's in control of
that it's just all
spontaneously apparently
happening
so there's no one that is
controlling period there's no one that's
controlling it's just boundlessly free
Always Forever already boundlessly free
and
whole
so it's way simple it's so ordinary
there's no specialness about it at all
none me is a hilarious huc ination of
specialness within
wholeness
because only
wholeness avoiding apparently avoiding
itself uses this Center Point use this
uses this
me to avoid being
no thing everything
in but that's just the
story it's ridiculous so
ridiculous
there's a question in the chat about
psychedelics as
always there's always this the me is so
attached
to a cause it wants a
cause this is not it this is not it so I
need a cause for it to be
nothing it's always already nothing
being everything it's already
that it's already
that it's not caused by psychedelic or
book or Guru or
Retreat or healing or Shadow work or
psychotherapy
or
traveling or material
possessions it's not caused it is not
caused it's hilariously not
caused but me the appearance of me can't
help but constantly be obsessed about
what is the cause what is the cause for
wholeness what is the
cause what is
it and like was said in the last episode
on
unknowing the most psychedelic thing
imaginable is
me
wholeness is absolutely ordinary and
natural however an apparent contracted
Center Point in a body that is lacking
and
needing and seeking however that
apparently happens that's the most
psychedelic thing
imaginable
and me thrives on these
stories so if me can get another me to
start sharing about
experiences and
Retreats and psychedelics and gurus and
books and all kinds of things then what
it does is it justifies and validates
the existence of the apparent and me
that's listening so that it itself can
continue going on its transformative
journey and believing ah there will be
wholeness one day there will be Freedom
one
day and so there is just a
cessation of validating the existence of
an elusory
individual
the
cessation of the validation of an
elusory
individual so whatever is watching
whatever is hearing that is nothing that
is nothing that doesn't have location it
doesn't have time it doesn't have
identity
doesn't have
name that is
infinity that is it it's already here
it's right there it's already free and
whole right there everywhere it's
already
that not after something happens then it
will be that it's already
that and that's why
this it's already that you know it's
already it's all
ready it's already it's already
it's
already it's already wholeness already
free already without location without
position
centerless no thing it's already
that it's already that
everying
it's
everything
everything everying
everying
appearing as
bodies
names
appearing as bodies
appearing as
names
appearing as a
contracted me in
body mutually assuring
destruction with military industrial
complexes
nuclear weapons separation across
Nations and
religion fighting over resources and
trillions of
dollars the most beautiful
story
and the
wholeness that always
is the wholeness that always
is the
wholeness that
always
already
is not later not to be
attained not an
acquisition not an
acquisition always already free here now
everywhere
nothing nothing everything
[Music]
nothing mystery
ineffable
everying nothing mystery ineffable
everything
so it's so simple man it's really so
simple
that urge that pattern that muscle that
lack that experience of contraction in
the body which is I am
not I am not whole I am not
worthy I am not everything
thing that is an
illusion that is an
illusion that is an illusion I will be
whole after
I've saw that Post online that offered a
course and then I became whole that's an
[Music]
illusion
and me hates hearing that because me
thrives on journey of a
story of transformation over time to
reach
wholeness and it's hilarious there's all
kinds of stories of decades oh man I've
been seeking 50 years I have a big big
bright golden golden star on my forehead
that says seeking for 50
years I've seen a dozen gurus in my
life I've read a thousand books on
spirituality look at my big
big gold star on my
forehead listen to all of my stories
validate
me I'm not
whole and I'll listen to your stories
and validate you not being whole and
then
colie just cuts just cuts The Duality
cuts it because it's already not
there it's already not
there there's already no individual
there's already no story of
transformation over time into wholeness
there's already only wholeness There and
Everywhere there's already only
wholeness everywhere that's
it that's
it oh
it's quite simple quite
ordinary it's not
special the most
simple imaginable it's just
this
this very
effortlessly
Dows it naturally and spontaneously
just
creates the decentralized autonomous
organizations decentralizing basic needs
people being
free no one being free it's already free
it's no one appear appearing to
be caught in a
matrix but it's already no
thinging it's
that that
unconditional love and feeling and
frequency of the cat purring the dog
pet the baby the child play the
Innocence the
unknowing always and
already
well it's been
fun it's been
fun these visuals uh
Freedom or the ineffable is not possible
to visualize
just being released in The Ether and
just that current
flowing it feels really
good
the
urgency to map no
longer the urgency to collect
Concepts and
ideas and visualize what this is no
longer because it's not possible to
conceptualize to
ideate
this simply
this the freedom that is already
always that can't be bound it can't be
put into Maps it
can't it's absolutely futile to put into
Maps
and the
videos the streams the conversations on
the channel being more and more
about always already
wholeness always already Freedom always
already unconditional love
everything and not validating the
elusory individual on a transformative
journey to wholeness that is also
mutually assured destruction in
apparently that will
be exciting and magnetizing and fun and
dawing and there will be events and and
all kinds of fun
things that
will be played on
together
and there will also be me that hates
this and that's also just again
wholeness apparently meing and
apparently hating it not being
validated
wholeness
meing refuses to be
invalidated and then it
attacks sometimes colie when collie says
you're not real your story St is not
real you don't exist there is only
wholeness there is only Freedom only
locationless position unconditional love
appearing as everything which
invalidates the story loops and Neurosis
of a Center Point called a
me that is constantly lacking and
needing and grabbing and objectifying
and manipulating the
appearance and so when collie cuts those
dualistic roots and undermines and
undermines and undermines
repeatedly
me will that either that little pinhole
of the ineffable will there will be a
relief a relaxation and an opening up to
what always already
is or there will just be a screw this
onto the next
experience cuz me me wants to try to
experience its way out of Separation
that isn't
already the separation already isn't
there is always already only
wholeness oh my
goodness it is literally saying the same
thing like a broken record endless
ways there's only wholeness that's the
only
isness is
wholeness what else can be said about
the ineffable nothing nothing can ever
be said about it and wholeness isness is
the closest you can get you can't get
closer than wholeness ising wholeness
everything wholeness
everything
it's always been no one it's always been
no one that's so clearly seen by nothing
when that apparent individual dissolves
it was never actually there it never
actually happened it's not happening
right now it's already not
happening
it's always already not happening me is
always already not happening only
wholeness is missing only wholeness and
it's hilarious cuz there's
uh me can also want
to be the change that the world
needs the way to be the change that the
world needs is through absence through
the dissolution of the center point that
isn't actually
there by not
meing by hessing that's the change that
the world
needs the ultimate morality and ethics
is through the absence of
me perfect timing
[Music]
without any
meaning just is it just is it simply
just
is it's so simple it's way too simple
it's way too
simple it's way too
ordinary
it can't be
known it just already
is it can't be grabbed and put into a
box or an object to be attained or
owned or that gold
star of in light or
awakened it can't be that because it's
already
nothing everything it's already that
it's always that it can't not be that
can't not be
that can't not be
wholeness can't not be
wholeness
it can't not be everything in it can't
not be
nothing it's always that it's always
nothing it's always everything it's
always
wholeness and so it just hyper
undermines the elusory
individual on a transformative Journey
or on a path to mutually assur
destruction through its needing need
need lack lack lack want want want more
more
more must
have top military grade Weaponry to
protect my ucer bounded
Nation must have top military weaponry
to annihilate the other which
isn't
there's already no
separation always already no
separation hey this is a live
stream just answering a live
chat always already no
separation
and it's so obvious there is
no there's no not a
single bit of Separation here not a
single bit of
Separation it's so blatantly obvious
it's
so
obvious that there's only
wholeness it's so simple and ordinary
it's so
ordinary wholeness overlooking itself
always it never really does it just
apparently does as of
Mirage as a
dream wholeness dreaming a Center Point
called me is the only dream the only
dream is that wholeness has a center
point the only dream is that wholeness
has a center point that is called Karen
or Bob or
Sam and that that Center Point is on a
journey to wholeness
it again it just doesn't matter which
country's names you put here which is
fascinating and that same thing's true
in this scale and variant version too
it's unbelievable it just it doesn't
matter all of infinity everything
thinging has no separation has no
bounds is
just wholeness dreaming a center
point there are no Center
points this is so simple
it's way it's crazy how simple it really
is thanks on the nice voice
chat the ASMR is heating up on the
channel there's more ASMR content that's
coming it's really exciting there will
be one later today that
will start things
off oh
boy it's so simple it's so simple
there's no complexity to this this this
ordinary
this
this this happening appearing simple
isness
it's so
easy
okay thanks for tuning
in infinite unconditional love as
[Music]
always so simple
so
ordinary this
Freedom
wholeness Always
Forever
already
is
[Music]
yay
bye
thanks